et aujourd'hui c'était une opération
recrutement au pôle emploi de guyancourt
qui s'est déroulée jusqu'à 16 heures
lagence a proposé un job dating à
plusieurs entreprises
une opération menée à l'échelle
régionale puisqu'elle s'inscrit dans le
cadre des jeudis de l'emploi le dernier
jeudi du mois les agences franciliennes
organise ces rencontres entre employeurs
et candidats
cette fois le recrutement était axée
vers les publics dits sensibles les
jeunes les seniors et les demandeurs
d'emploi longue durée cinq entreprises
se sont prêtés au jeu
une quarantaine de postes étaient à
pourvoir pour une cinquantaine de
candidats on écoutait la responsable
céline saint joanis nous donner plus de
précision elle était au micro de camille
lambert
l'intérêt c'est qu'ils doivent se
présenter très rapidement puisque les
entretiens sont de 15 à 20 minutes
et puis d'avoir accès directement à
l'employeur ce qui n'arrive pas
forcément à faire qu'en utilisant voix
seule leur cv ça s'inscrit en lien avec
le plan 500000 formation du gouvernement
donc qui prévoit l'entrée en formation
de 500 mille demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires qui grâce à cette
formation auront un retour à l'emploi
plus rapide et donc c'est pour ça que
nous avons favorisé également les
mesures pour l'emploi de type
préparation opérationnelle à l'emploi
contrats de professionnalisation et
individuel à la formation